after Star Wars The Force awakens
moviegoers around the world fell in love
with Poe Dameron a loyal soldier a good
friend and a heroic leader he's not
afraid to crack jokes when squaring off
against lightsaber wielding psychos and
a dude can fly any ship you put in front
of him whether it's an x-wing or a TIE
fighter but best of all damron is played
by Oscar Isaac one of the most talented
actors in Hollywood today and while
Isaac might be best known for Star Wars
his resume includes everything from
indie thrillers to superhero
blockbusters here all the places you've
seen Poe Dameron before the Nativity
story for his fifth feature film Oscar
Isaac landed the part of Joseph one of
the most important but least
acknowledged characters to have been
involved in the birth of Jesus despite
that lack of background info Isaac
totally succeeds in bringing his
biblical character to life playing
Joseph as a virtuous man who sticks by
his betrothed Mary even when she
mysteriously becomes pregnant with the
Son of God Body of Lies one of Ridley
Scott's lesser-known films Body of Lies
follows a CIA agent played by Leonardo
DiCaprio who's hunting insurgents across
the Middle East but despite his fluent
Arabic and scraggly beard DiCaprio can't
win the entire Iraq war by himself so he
needs a bit of backup from his sidekick
and field operative Bassam sporting
ponytail and a machine gun but some is
the guy who covers DiCaprio when the
going gets rough unfortunately he also
doesn't live very long getting blown
into little bits by an RPG during the
first act but despite his limited screen
time
Isaac totally holds his own against the
Caprio right up until he's turned into
human toast Robin Hood just a few years
after Body of Lies Oscar Isaac Reed
teamed with Ridley Scott for a grittier
take on England's most famous outlaw
played by Russell Crowe this film didn't
do especially well with critics or
audiences but Isaac's sleazy turn as the
infamous Prince John was a standout as a
man obsessed with taxing peasants and
cheating on his wife Isaac took full
advantage of every opportunity to chew
the scenery standing around naked and
generally come off as a royal jerk you
King and the runt of the litter to call
you sucker-punch this 2011 film by Zack
Snyder tells the story of baby doll
played by Emily Browning who's framed
for murder and shipped off to a horrific
1950s mental asylum in order to cope she
escapes into her subconscious where she
encounters dragons nazi robots and of
course this guy oscar isaac plays blue
jones
and orderly at the mental asylum who
becomes a slick temp in baby dolls
fantasy world the dual role gave isaac
lots of room to show off his acting
chops and his sexy singing voice drive
there is no denying that ryan gosling is
the star of drive but oscar isaac is
pivotal to the plot of this 1970s style
thriller isaac plays an ex-con who's
hoping to start his life anew and set
things right with his wife played by
Carey Mulligan
which is complicated by the presence of
Gosling as the cool quiet neighbor on
whom she's developed a crush hey she's
only human despite a tense introduction
the two men end up collaborating on a
criminal scheme but Isaac's character
doesn't make it to the end credits
however his death sets off a chain of
events that culminates in the most
gruesome elevator beatdown in the
history of film The Bourne Legacy what
the fourth Bourne film lacks in Matt
Damon it makes up in Oscar Isaac this
time the up-and-comer plays the
enigmatic number three a government
operative who's being punished for
falling in love on the job relocated to
a cabin in the middle of Alaska he
survives just long enough on screen to
give star Jeremy Renner a helping hand
before being wiped out by an assassin
drone inside Llewyn Davis written and
directed by the Coen brothers this is
the movie that finally put Oscar Isaac
on the radar of Hollywood and audiences
alike he earned a Golden Globe
nomination for his performance as the
title character a musician struggling to
make it in New York's folk music scene
whether he's auditioning for a
hard-bitten music producer verbally
sparring with John Goodman or carrying a
cat through Manhattan you can't help but
root for this guy
[Music]
the cat Lewin has the cat plus you've
got a love watching Oscar Isaac perform
a duet with Adam driver long before they
meet again as enemies in the force
awakens a most violent year set in 1981
this movie from 2014 finds Oscar Isaac
playing Abel Morales an immigrant
businessman with big plans and even
bigger problems the owner of a heating
oil company Abel plans on taking control
of the Big Apple but first he needs to
raise enough money for a pricey piece of
real estate tangle with the district
attorney and discover who's stealing his
oil with the beautiful and brutal
Jessica Chastain egging him on Isaac's
conflicted character has to decide if he
should take the high road or another
kind of path ex machina Oscar Isaac is
that it's bad guy best here playing a
tech genius named Nathan a man with the
freaky ambitions of a Frankenstein and
the tech savvy of a Zuckerberg in a
movie where everyone is on their a game
including Alicia vikander in the role of
a seductive robot Isaac completely
steals the show boozing with menacing
contempt bullying his AI creation and
tearing up the dance floor in one of the
movie's most memorable scenes x-men
apocalypse no Hollywood resume is
complete without a superhero flick and
Oscar Isaac gave the genre go with this
one in which he plays a blue skinned
mutant with a serious god complex
after napping for a couple of millennia
apocalypse emerges from his tomb decides
he hates the 80s and prepares for world
domination only to discover that he
stumbled into one of the worst films of
the x-men franchise yeah critics hated
x-men apocalypse and American audiences
weren't crazy about it either
meaning poor Isaac spent hours under all
that makeup only to have his character
criticized as an incredible letdown but
while he didn't find success as a mutant
Oscar Isaac is set for life as a Star
Wars hero so it all works out in the end
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]